le plateau sportif de traînel présenté à
patrick kanner si on a 21 demandes on
organisait un peu plus loin ce jardin
partagé sous la responsabilité des
jeunes des différentes associations du
quartier
donc vous vous auriez un gestionnaire
traisnel environ 8000 habitants des
constructions qui date des années 50 une
habitation spontanées parfois d'accès
difficile le ministre de la ville de la
jeunesse et des sports découvre ainsi ce
qui est fait et reste à faire en termes
de résorption de l'habitat insalubre et
de rénovation urbaine
un énorme chantier peau fort de france
c'est une travail immense qui est devant
nous on le sait il faut commencer
il a déjà commencé mais la question du
coup si vous voulez viendra plus tard
c'est le programme de l'anru un
représenté 47 milliards d'euros de
travaux sur le territoire national et
aussi bien sûr sur les outre-mer là on
part sur 20 à 25 milliards nous verrons
bien en tant que tel moi ce qui
m'intéresse d'abord c'est la
qualification du projet est-ce que ça va
vraiment changer la vie des gens
est ce que les habitants seront associés
à la démarche du projet toutes ces
réponses je les ai une manière positive
il y à quelques instants donc je pars
très confiant sept quartiers sont cités
grosses roches terres sainville citron
très nette hexago volga plage et sainte
thérèse à un programme sur plusieurs
décennies
c'est un travail qui a déjà commencé et
qu'il faut poursuivre c'est un travail
d'aménagement d'une ville ce n'est pas à
l'échelle d'une mandature ce n'est pas à
l'échelle de du quotidien si vraiment on
travaille dans la durée c'est un travail
important et qu'il faut entendre qu'il
faut poursuivre et surtout poursuivre
aujourd'hui de mon contenu en associant
les habitants
après la guadeloupe et la martinique
patrick kanner s'apprête à faire plus
ample connaissance avec la guyane
dès ce soir